hello believe nation today I'm going to
talk about the seven mistakes that are
standing between you and your big break
a lot of people aren't where they should
be a lot of people are not getting the
results that they should be getting with
their talent with their skill with their
love they are not where they want to be
they're not hitting their goals they're
not having the impact that they could
have they're not making the money that
they should make they're not reaching
people like they should and it's because
they continue to do these seven mistakes
over and over and over and over again
and hopefully by shining the light on
them by giving you guys some awareness
about them you can recognize if this is
a pattern in your life that you need to
break through to reach a success that
you're after
so mistake number one is working on your
weaknesses and this might be a little
counterintuitive because we tend to look
at what we're not good at and say oh I
need to get better at that I need to
improve I need to fix that weakness
there was a story on my channel that I
heard recently and I thought I wanted to
share it on this video where it says
bunny that is going to school and he got
an A in hopping and he was failing his
swimming and so his parents look at that
and they say oh you're not really doing
well at swimming you got to work on that
and they give him extra lessons and
private tutoring and every day after
school he's going swimming and swimming
and swimming and swimming and then
finally he becomes you know he gets a
passable grade he becomes an average
swimmer but in that process he forgets
how to hop and what's a bunny made to do
hop right Michael Jordan is fantastic at
playing basketball he doesn't need to
know French he doesn't need to know how
to make a pillow there's a million
things that he doesn't need to do he
needs to focus I want he's great at and
the same thing for you you need to focus
on what you can be one of the best in
the world at what you can have Michael
level talent and genius at and go all in
on that because otherwise you're a
mediocre generalist at a whole bunch of
things but you're never able to have the
impact that you want
stop trying to swim when you should be
hopping
mistake number two is thinking you can
do everything alone
this is temptation to say I'm gonna do
everything by myself I'm the best at
what I do
nobody cares as much as I do nobody has
the skills that I do it's gonna go all
in on my own you cannot achieve massive
success by yourself you need to have a
team you need to have people with you to
help you with your cause to help you
build the business that you want to
build otherwise you're always gonna be
limited you only have so many hours in
the day and you can automate you can
make yourself as efficient as possible
but you still only have 24 hours in the
day you know Steve Jobs Howard Schultz
AP Giannini only had 24 hours in a day
that's it where you get the leverage is
using other people's time as well and I
know it can be hard maybe you've tried
hiring somebody and it didn't work out
and you say forget it you know that
person I hired I put so much effort into
hiring them when they made all those
mistakes and I just had to monitor them
it took me more work than me doing it
myself and you need to learn to be a
better hire you need to learn to be a
better manager you need to learn to
bring on the right people most companies
the first person I hire is not still
with the company a few years later and
something that first person sucked is
that the company didn't know how to hire
the entrepreneur didn't know how to hire
the attorney didn't know how to manage
you can't just put somebody into a job
and poof except tend to be magic chances
are your first couple hires are not
gonna work out you're learning a new
skill that you don't know before you
can't mail it in after that though you
can't have one bad hire and say forget
it I'm never gonna hire again in order
to get to where you need to go you have
to bring on a team to round out those
weaknesses so you can focus on those
strengths you can focus on the big
picture
visionary stuff so you can focus on the
thing that you are best in the world
that and you have the people around you
to support everything else up
mistake number three is listening to the
little man the little man is a person
your life was telling you all the
reasons why you can't do something it's
the person that when you show your
business plan or your idea to all they
did was poke the holes in the plan and
tell you all the reasons why it'll never
work and tell you that you don't have
the education you don't have the
upbringing you're not from the right
country and you you know the government
will never support you know all the
reasons why this thing will never work
and the mistake is listening to them
right because as entrepreneurs we get
this moment of boldness we get excited
where we have this vision we get this
idea for what we want to accomplish and
it's 3:00 in the morning we wake up say
this is what I want to do and then you
wake up the next day and that energy is
gone or maybe you wake up the next day
and you tell somebody and they say
that's what that's what you want to do
and then immediately just by their
reaction you you get all cowardly right
is it and you say think oh maybe that's
not a good idea
maybe I shouldn't do that because of
this one person's opinion who has never
done what you are trying to do and even
if they love you they haven't done what
you trying why you listening to this
person who has not done what you want to
do how is their advice meaningful to you
if anything that you want to do the
opposite because what they're saying may
be out of love because they want to see
you take a safe more traditional path
but they were advice is going to help
you take the same path as then and if
that's the path you want to take great
but if that's not the path then you
shouldn't be talking to them in this
circumstance your parents may be able to
help you be a great person they may be
help you be a great husband or great
wife or a great mother a great father
but if they're not if they don't refer
themselves they can't give you the
business advice to help you go out and
chase your dream more importantly to the
little man inside your head the person
inside your head is telling you like I
can't do that I don't have the skills I
don't have the knowledge I don't have
the money I don't the connections all
the resources I don't the education I
can't do that and whenever you catch
yourself in those moments telling
yourself why you can't do something try
to stomp it out look yourself in the
mirror and say I can't be successful I
can't reach my goal because and what is
that what's that because fill in that
blank for yourself that's the limiting
belief that you've been telling yourself
your entire life until you crush it
you're never going to get to where you
could go to be that best version of
yourself
mistake number four is being afraid to
fail failure is not this final thing
failure is not just like I failed and
then therefore I will never be
successful
look at the most successful people in
your field outside your field it doesn't
matter they failed and they failed and
they failed and they failed and they
failed and then they became successful
it's a story of everybody's success
nobody just hits it and boom never makes
a mistake and is off for the rest of
their life so many people try something
and they fail at it and they never get
back off the mat they never try it again
because I tried that you know and and it
didn't work so I can't do it again and I
get it and it sucks especially if it's
in a in a public arena especially if
you're you know telling your friends and
family I'm gonna be an entrepreneur and
you take your shot and you miss and you
fail that can be really hard you know
hopefully you don't have friends and
family who are kind of laughing at you
are making fun of you that can be hard
to get up and do it again the only
situation where failure is actually
failure is if you haven't learned
something if you learn from it then
you've become a better entrepreneur and
the key is to not try to take huge big
risks so that you have huge big failures
but you have a lot of little failures
you try something you don't invest your
money invest your time invest your
energy invest your hustle try see if it
works see if you get results if you love
it see if it makes you come alive if it
doesn't great that's not a failure it
just didn't work I learned from that I'm
not gonna do that again I'm gonna do
something else try that small invest
your time energy hustle not your dollars
your time see if that works if not one
of the next thing continue to explore
continue to try and every time you learn
you get a little bit better but being
afraid that something's not gonna work
out if that's your mindset going in
you're never gonna do anything big
because you will always fail at stuff
and it's who the failures that you learn
mistake number five is blaming your
circumstances so many people blame other
things other people their environment on
why they are not successful I'm not
successful because you know my parents
don't believe in me
I'm not concessional because you know I
come from another country and I'm an
immigrant I'm not successful because I
don't live in America I'm not successful
because my parents didn't send me to an
Ivy League school I'm not successful
because I don't have a million dollars
in my bank account whatever it is right
it's always somebody else's fault and
until you take responsibility for your
life you know in the early years okay
great you know you're you're living
under somebody else's expectations
you're doing what your parents tell you
to do because that's your environment
growing up but when you become an adult
you know you're an adult this is your
life now you can change things just
because somebody has expectations on you
it doesn't mean you have to do it you
have to decide whether you're going to
live your version of your life or
somebody else's version of your life and
too many people set these outside
circumstances ads that story that as
long as you believe it as long as you
believe you're never going to be
successful because you didn't get a
university education if that's your
story then you never want where there's
been tons of people who have way worse
situations than you do and they achieve
success you know but by the fact that
you're watching this video you know you
have a computer you have an internet
access you probably have some food you
know your electricity bill is being paid
you're already way ahead than most of
the world you're already way ahead than
somebody who's gonna create the next
game-changing thing and take off because
they didn't let their story their
circumstances dictate where they can go
mistake number six is not taking
immediate action I've very talked about
this a little bit when you have that
moment of boldness and you think a big
idea you get all excited all confident
all energized like this is it this is my
next big thing I'm so pumped
I'm so excited by and then you wake up
the next thing that energy is gone and
you're not feeling like oh that was too
big an idea I can't do that Who am I to
do that the key to combating that is not
waiting don't wait until tomorrow it's
easy to say this is so exciting tomorrow
I'm gonna go do this and then it's more
you wake up see I'm not sure maybe
tomorrow and then next thing you wake up
and poof the idea is already gone forget
about it you've already fallen back into
your your mindset your way of doing
things your limited thinking and then
you'll never take action on it where the
key is to start building momentum
immediately as soon as you set a goal
for yourself like a goal is something
that is challenging is different it
stretches your comfort zone it pushes
you to be better version yourself and
because it pushes you it's painful right
it sucks to have to go through some of
that stuff if it was easy then it
wouldn't really be much of a goal and so
because it's painful you don't want to
do it and as soon as you lose motivation
and energy for it it's gonna fall off
the plate because it's too painful for
you you don't wanna do those activities
it stretches you too much so the key is
immediately take some kind of action and
ideally with somebody else right you're
more likely to stick to a gym program if
you sign up with somebody else it's just
like any other goal right if I have a
goal to accomplish something then first
thing I do is I try to email somebody
set up a meeting hey I have this idea I
want to do XYZ can you meet next week to
talk about it now even if the next day I
wake up and I'm like bowing down like
you that maybe it's too big an idea I've
committed like I've got to go meet that
person next week I'm not gonna back down
and say you know what I didn't really
believe in that idea anymore all right
I feel committed to following through
and so even if it's some small tiny
action right it's not this big huge step
we're gonna take some small tiny action
take it immediately as soon as you said
any goal for yourself in your life or in
your business
and mistake number seven is not having
self-awareness this is what I talk about
a lot in my my new book your one word
understanding your values understanding
who you are living your life and create
the business on purpose a lot of people
are just constantly being reactionary
you're just reacting to the things that
are happening to you your your morning
is a reaction to what has to get done
right your entire day just is a reacting
emails and putting up fires and just
constantly reacting to other people
instead of with intent planning out your
day your business your life so
understanding what it is that you stand
for what's the one word that you stand
for how does that then filter out
through your company through the people
that you connect with through the rest
of your life so that you are living with
intent
you're living with design and sometimes
that plan falls apart sometimes
emergencies happen that comes up but my
goal is to live in no crisis life to not
have to have to have a no crisis
business and it's not 100% attainable
but it's pretty close you can design way
more than you give yourself credit for
and instead of an easy way to start
instead of just waking up and reacting
to your day planning design it here is
how I'm going to spend the first hour of
my day every day these are the things
that in order for me to be a success in
order for me to get to where I want to
go but for me to achieve those things
this is the kind of person I need to be
and these are the habits that I need to
keep and it's a schedule that will allow
me to keep those habits and put it in
and stick to it
plan it design it and that's the easy
place to start that first hour of the
day what are you spending your time on
and then stick to that schedule instead
of reacting to the things around you so
that's my take on the 7 mistakes that
are standing between you and your big
break I'd love to know what you think
did you like the video which one of the
seven meant the most to you do you
resonate most with did I miss one or the
really eight or nine or 10 leave it in
the comments below and I will join in
the discussion I also want to give a
quick shout out to ten more weeks
Tamara ordered 10 copies of my book
Tamara thank you so much it means the
world to me
for those of you watching if you want
your chance at a shadow in a future
video make sure to pick up a copy of the
book and then email
in the receipts so we can enter you into
the draw thank you guys so much for
watching
continue to believe or whatever your one
word is and I'll see you soon